all righty
it's a time to start I think
so um this talk is called building
confidence in concurrent code using a
model Checker AKA TLA Plus for
programmers it's a bit of a mouthful
hopefully by the end of the talk um you
will see what I'm talking about
now um I'm Scott volocian you probably
know me from my functional programming
talks and also from my domain modeling
talks
this is nothing to do with that this is
all about having confidence how you test
your codes it's not testing code but how
do you have confidence in your designs
so I actually I'm going to ask you in a
minute about confidence I'm going to be
testing your ability to look at code and
see whether it's right or not so there
is a poll I'll show this link later on
but hopefully you had a chance to look
at it but I will show a big version in
in a few minutes it's bitly slash TLA
poll 2023.
right okay so why am I focusing on
concurrent code in particular
that's because there's two groups of
people there's people who write
concurrent covered and people have had
painful bugs and can count code and of
course this is actually a perfect circle
because concurrent code is horrible
anyone's actually done anything with the
comica it's like it's really nasty stuff
so
um this talk is really about confidence
right how do you increase your
confidence in your code and what tools
can you use to increase your confidence
right so there's a toolbox of tools that
we use I mean a classic one is to do
code review or code inspection right I
look at your code it's nice to get
another pair of eyeballs on your code
make sure it's looking good I really
like static typing that eliminates a lot
of stuff at compile time it's kind of
like compile time unit tests really nice
I'm also a big fan of property based
testing that's a great way to increase
your confidence in the code things like
tdd all the classic techniques you know
it's all about increasing the confidence
in your code
and this talk is about this thing called
Model checking
which is probably for most of you a
brand new concept so that's what this
talk is about a whole new tool to add to
your toolbox
now what I mean by model checking well
what's a model so a model is a tool for
thinking so before I spend a lot of
money building a building for example I
make make a model of the building and I
can use the model to make sure I'm happy
with it the way it looks and I haven't
kind of forgotten anything I can show it
other people and get feedback
so models are a way to make sure that
you're doing the right thing before you
spend a lot of money building the
massive building right
so it's just a way of making sure stuff
makes sense before you do more something
which is much more expensive
so model checking that I'm talking about
is again you create a model of your code
you don't actually write the code you
create a model of the code before you do
it and then you check the model and the
kinds of things you check are all the
constraints met you know does anything
weird happen when you check the model
especially if you're doing concurrent
code you know does it deadlock does it
ever finish does it reach a state that
you expect to reach all that kind of
stuff so we're checking the model before
we even write the real code so this is
part of formal methods
four methods it's kind of mathematical
approach to to code quality this is
actually the very easy one this is like
the simplest intro to all this stuff so
there's a couple of model Checkers you
can use there's actually a whole bunch
of them but the two most popular ones is
something called
TLA plus which is actually a whole
system
and TLC is the actual model Checker
within and I'm not even going to get
into all the other stuff in Taylor plus
I'm just going to focus this in one
thing and it focuses really on temporal
property something to do with time okay
so it's great for doing concurrent
systems now there's another one which is
quite public called alloy and that's
much better on kind of relational logic
and and relationship between structures
and so on so that's also very good but
in this talk I'm going to be focusing on
TLA because of the the benefit it has in
modeling concurrent systems okay so at
the end of this talk he'll know
something about TLA Plus
so this is what TLA Plus Code looks like
and you know it looks weird right I mean
this is the weirdest looking programmer
language that you know I've ever seen
when I first saw this this is a strange
program language well the reason it's a
strange programming is because it's not
a programming language right it's not a
program it's a modeling language it's a
DSL for modeling States and time
so you might look at this and think this
is kind of weird but hopefully by the
end of this talk you'll be able to look
at this and not think it's weird
so that's the goal of this talk now
obviously in one talk you can't really
become an expert just like in any
programming language you can't you know
learn it in a few in an hour but if the
point of this talk is demystify this to
just take some of the uh the the fear
around using a tool like this and so
it's actually not that hard to use and
it's worth spending a bit of time
learning
so let's do some first live poll here is
the live poll I'm going to use and let
me get this started
right
so the first hopefully everyone has got
this up now it's bitly TLA poll 2023 or
there's the big QR code here
business and I will show this again
later on if you didn't quite get it but
let's just see what the results are 100
of people can see this poll
excellent nobody said no that was very
nice
okay so this poll seems to be working
pretty well
okay good oh some people say no
some people are just mean okay or they
don't know how to use the internet
right okay so some people are
not going to be very good here okay so
okay that's the poll
right so I'm going to be asking you
later on some more serious questions so
the talk this talk is basically going to
start about I'm going to have some stuff
about confidence and then I'm going to
introduce TLA plus I'm going to show you
all that syntax and and show you there's
not as weird as it looks and then I'm
going to want through three examples
first of all I'm going to do a really
really simple model which is counting to
three
hopefully that will be pretty simple
then I'll actually do a very classic
producer consumer model where they talk
to each other through a queue and then
I'll actually do something which is kind
of relevant to what we actually do which
is maybe a zero downtime deployment so
we're in charge of deploying some
servers
and you want to make sure you have a
zero downtime what algorithm should you
use to do that and if you mess it up
you're going to have down time so it's
kind of important
okay so let's start with confidence
so I'm going to show you a
non-concurrent algorithm this is just a
regular old sort algorithm to sort a
list this is the algorithm that we're
going to use if the list is empty or has
one element it's sorted we're done
otherwise we take the first element
which I'm calling the pivot and I'm
dividing the rest of the list into two
piles one smaller than the pivot one is
bigger than the pivot and then I take
these two piles and I sort them using
the same algorithm and then I combine
the whole thing and I put the sorted
smaller list and then I have my Pivot
and then I have the bigger sorted list
okay so that's how I'm going to sort a
list okay
so do you have confidence that this
algorithm is correct not not in
implementation
but this algorithm is this is this a
correct if I if I then write this code
am I going to is it going to work okay
that's my my check for you
so that's my first poll question
what is the confidence in the design of
this algorithm it's basically a quick
sort kind of Outlet it's not really a
quick saw but it's you know a cursive
sorting algorithm
hopefully you've seen this kind of thing
before
now you should have 100 confidence one
way or the other whether it works
because the code's right in front of you
and it's only you know
10 lines of code
so if you don't all have 100 confidence
I'm going to be very upset
and we have a mixture between people who
are confident people who are not
confident and people aren't confident
either way
and uh this is very interesting so
the people who are not who are not
confident either way
what could I do to make you more
confident
right what kinds of things could I do
and if you thought it wasn't confidence
if you if you thought it wasn't correct
what could I do to prove that it was
correct or if it was correct what could
I do to prove that it wasn't correct
okay
so the fact that it's not 100 in this
room you know it's typical it's typical
people are not very confident about
their code
so actually that's actually that's Azure
bug
so all of the people who said this was
right you're not right there's a bug
here
and the bug is actually should be I had
strictly less than strictly greater than
they should be greater or equal less
than equal because I'm throwing away
duplicate pivots
so there's a little bug
which you didn't catch so how would you
catch the bug like that well one thing
is code of view I mean I could go in and
say so you forgot to do the you know
the less than uh you made it too strict
another way is to do an implementation I
you know I write this code in python or
JavaScript or something I test it I'm a
big fan of using property based tests
because that would catch it pretty
straight away I'm pretty sure rather
than just unit tests you might not catch
it because you might forget to put
duplicates in but a property-based test
will pull it capture straight away or
you could actually prove it using a
mathematical proof resistant which
nobody no programmer would ever do that
as far as I know
so personally I'd use a combination of
both I'd have somebody else eyeball it
make sure they're happy and they're not
pulling right some probably based tests
and if you want to know what probably
based tests are I have a whole talk
about that if you go to F sharp 100
profit PBT and I'll have that link up
later on as well
now that was that was a a non-concurrent
algorithm and we still had a big
difference now let's talk about the
currency
how confident are you when concurrency
is involved
all right so I'm going to give you a
concurrent thing so this is a very
simple producer consumer system we have
a queue and we have a producer that
writes the queue and the producer logic
is I'm going to see if the queue is not
full
and if it's not full then I can write to
it but if it's full I don't want to you
know it's a bounded queue
and then we have a consumer that's
reading from the queue and they're going
to say well if the queue is not empty
then I can read from it but if it is
empty I'm just going to wait and they
could just kind of loop around the
producers and consumers are going to be
looping around okay so that's the system
okay so here's the complete spec
we have a bounded queue we have a
producer and a consumer and it's really
important that we never read from an
empty queue or write to a full code we
don't underflow our overflow and let's
say the whole system is going to crash
and bring down Azure for example
so here's the spec and here is the
consumer specs so again the algorithm is
really simple I mean it's actually
simpler than the sort algorithm
who thinks this is a correct design
foreign
there's one purchaser and one consumer
yeah
and it's a trap it's a trick question
it's always a trick question when it's
concurrency right so try that poll and
tell me
if you think this is a correct yeah so
for one producer one consumer and later
on we'll talk about more than one and
more than two but for one producer one
consumer is this the correct algorithm
to use
let's see what people say here oh okay
we have a big difference of opinion here
and what's interesting is that most
people are not confident
now how this is really simple I mean how
much simpler could you get
you just got you know there's like two
lines of two or three lines of code for
the producer two three lines of code for
the consumer they're both running at the
same time
and nobody's confident that this code
works like a whole bunch of people know
and the people who you know there's a
big split between the correct people and
the incorrect people
so who's right and who's wrong and there
are people who are not confident
how could I persuade you you know I mean
I'd say let's say I say this is
absolutely right I'm really confident
this is why how would I persuade you
that I was you know that I was right
I mean you don't want to run it in
production because you might not show up
in production
so we're gonna revisit this one in a
minute
and um
will actually model it in TLA and we'll
actually get an answer
so like I say if you vote I'm not sure
how would I persuade you
now let's change it up and have two
producers and two consumers so with one
producer and one consumer and we'll go
to the next poll question now
um
with with one producer one consumer it
was 50 50 splits between correct and
Incorrect and there's a whole bunch of
people who weren't sure
and now we've changed it to two so it
has people's opinion changed
let's see
ah
a lot of people are confident that it's
not correct okay so anytime there's more
than one thing you know that's not gonna
work okay and there are a lot of there
are quite a few people who are not
confident either way but people it's
it's people are very suspicious like I
don't think this is going to work
because it's somehow it's multi-user and
there's concurrency and it's like I just
know it's not going to work
right so people are scared people are
scared of concurrent systems
especially when there's a lot of stuff
going on
Okay so
um
people who are not sure how could I
persuade you that it didn't work or did
work now the people who thought it
didn't work this is the big thing so I
say I'll have a fix for it
I'm going to use automatic Atomic
operations I'm going to use semaphores
I'm going to use a lock I'm going to use
whatever right
and I present to you my fix for this
problem
how how would I persuade you that my fix
was correct would you just say I never
trust it you know I'm just like never
going to believe it's going to work what
can I do to give you confidence and say
yeah actually you're fixed I'm pretty
sure that I'm really confident that your
fix is going to work and we can deploy
this to production
what would I have to tell you
okay so it's hard being being confident
in consistency is a really hard problem
now the tools that we normally use don't
work so if I do code review and
inspection I mean you're looking at the
code we have a whole bunch of people
looking at the code
I don't think our human brains are very
good and currency our intuition is just
rubbish so that's not going to work if I
create an implementation and then test
it that's not very good either because a
lot of subtle concurrency errors don't
show up in testing and they don't show
up in development they show up in
production when you have millions of
things and there's a very high load and
it always happens on the worst day of
the year you know so just running it is
not a very good way of doing either
so the answer is to use a mathematical
proof assistant tool but that's too much
mathematics we're going to use a model
Checker that's what we're going to do
so I'm going to revisit this problem
again with the model Checker and we'll
see for ourselves whether it works so
time to talk about TLA plus this is the
tool we're going to use to model this
and um again I'm going to whiz through
this very quickly it's a very short I
mean it's a you know it's a quick talk
but hopefully it's going to just
demystify it you don't have to worry
about the syntax too much and stand back
because I'm actually going to use
mathematics so be careful
and that's because it's not a
programming language it's mathematical
based model
so TLA plus was designed by Leslie
Lambert who you might have heard of he
had a famous time and clocks paper in
distributive programming he invented the
practice alcohol he's a touring Award
winner and relevant to this he is the
initial developer of latex
here he is a picture and the reason why
that's important is because TLA plus is
uses latex kind of syntax it's designed
to be formatted by latex into papers
computer science papers it's not
designed to be a program language which
is why it kind of looks weird so if you
know latex the syntax will be fine but
if you don't know latex it won't so
what does TLA plus stand for it stands
for temporal logic of actions Plus
all right what does that mean
logic so logic is something to do with
booleans
hopefully you know how to use booleans
so that's good temporal has something to
do with time
and actions in this thing is going to be
transitions in a state machine
so as you move from one state to another
that is an action or a transition so TLA
actually stands for Boolean logic of
State transitions over time now that's
that's a little bit less scary and we're
going to kind of dive into that in a
minute and then there's some other stuff
which we'll talk about later on
so let's look at the logic of the in TLA
so Boolean logic is what it is and um
it's and or not hopefully you all know
how that works
the big thing about TLA is the way that
they do booleans
is the mathematical way so in in maths
you have a kind of kind of uppercase a
there's an and and a kind of upside down
a is a is an or and that's what TLA plus
it uses forward slash and backslash so
if you look at the code you'll see these
forward slashes and backslashes
everywhere
and all that is is and and or
programming we use like ampersands and
vertical bars and stuff TLA plus does
not use that but it's the same exactly
the same concept so hopefully you
already know how to do that
and then another big concept
is something called a predicate so
predicate is just a expression and
returns a Boolean as always right so in
the programming language I might say
here's a function with a b and c and
it's a and b or a and not C right so the
whole thing returns a Boolean and you
just run it and each time you get a
different result but it's a Boolean
that's a predicate okay so TLA I'd write
the same thing in TLA like this I'd say
A and B that's the kind of a the letter
A or which is the upside down a and then
um a and not C so that's how you'd write
the same kind of piece of code in TLA so
there you go that's hopefully it's
instantly a little less scary just
knowing what those all those forward
slashes and backslashes mean
Now actions so State transitions
so you're probably familiar with State
machines but basically you have a bunch
of states and you have a bunch of
Transitions and that's how you model
um things it's a really nice tool it's
nothing I mean I use it for domain
modeling as well so here we can go from
A to B we can go from B to a we can go
from B to C but we can't go back from C
to B and this model kind of captures
that information very nice so you know
if you're modeling a chess game you can
model all this stuff people take turns
but what's nice you can see straight
away from this diagram that when when
somebody goes to the game over State you
can't go back to playing the game I mean
it's immediately obvious that transition
is not available right
here's something for like a delivery of
FedEx or something again you can see
that once it's delivered
you can't undeliver it
you can go back and forth in various
other ways but you know
um that is this design does not cover
that situation so let's look at the
transition in TLA so in TLA there's
always a before State and an after state
right so in this case the state before
is hello and the state after is goodbye
so until a we would say State equals
hello and then State tick
equals goodbye now every time you see
the tick or the prime of mathematical
jargon that means it's the after State
there's always a before and in every
single transition there's a poor one
after and so if it doesn't have a ticket
to the before and if it does have a tick
it's the after
so that's what those little ticks mean
everywhere
and this whole thing is an action
so I can give this a name like this is
the next action that you can do the next
transition you can do so in TLA plus I
would work like this I say next Double
equals that's the double equals it's not
assignment it's like you know
defining definition
um so the next operation is
at the beginning statements hello and
which that's the slashes and afterwards
the state is goodbye right so in English
we'd say you know before the state it's
low and after the state is goodbye and
that's the kind of formal way of writing
this down
so this equal sign is not an assignment
if you don't think about programming
variables think about the state before
and the state after this whole thing is
actually a predicate this is true if the
state is before or not you know like
that this is true and if the state
before and after is not like that it's
false so this thing is actually a
predicate it's an expression which turns
a Boolean and you can you can tell it's
a Boolean expression because you can
stop the order of the things
and it's the same answer so it's not
assignment it's it's more like pattern
matching it's like is this thing true or
not and that's how the model Checker
works
so here we have our little transition
and in the first case this transition is
true
in the second case
the the the after state is not right so
that does not match that's false in the
other one the the before state it
doesn't match and that's false two so
there's you know it's true and then
false and then false like I say it's a
predicate it was an expression
okay now let's look at time
so TLA
the transitions go on forever right it's
basically an infinite set of transitions
you start at something and think of it
like a clock tickings like it goes from
here to here and then here to here and
every time the clock ticks you have to
make another transition
okay now because it's a infinitely set a
lot infinitely a long series of
transitions you can ask questions you
can say is something always true
if something ever true does it ever
happen to be true you know if something
happens must something happen afterwards
can it you know is it does it require
that something happens afterwards so
that's the time thing so that is
everything about a TLA right so it's got
is Boolean logic of straight transitions
over time
and we'll talk about the plus later on
so that's the Syntax for TLA
now let's actually use it
to do a very simple model and we're
going to count to three okay how hard is
that
so here is our series of State
transitions right we go from one to two
to three there's two three states and
two transitions so we're going to model
that entirely
now in a programming language you would
say x equals one and then x equals two
and then x equals three right that's how
you do it in the program language we're
not making we're not going to do that in
telia plus it's going to be more
complicated than that
so the first thing we need to do is say
what is the initial state in the initial
State X is one
and then what are the available
transitions that we can do
well the first transition we can do is
true if we can do this transition if x
is 1 and then afterwards X is 2 so
that's a valid transition or
we can also do a transition if before X
is 2 and after X is 3 right so the
initial state is one
and then the first transition is the
before and after state of one and two
the second transition is the before and
after state of two and three and then
the overall all the possible transitions
we can do
is the first recession the first
transition or the second transition
right so the entire set of things you
can do is is the choice between those
two things
all right so that's how you get into
three
okay it's very very exciting
now let's just do a quick refactor you
can take little chunks of code and give
them names which is nice so here I've
taken out these two Transitions and I've
given them a name step one and step two
and now
the the overall thing is step one or
step two which is a little easier to
read
so these things are called operators in
TLA it's not like they're not little
functions they're actually more like
kind of macros they're kind of copy you
know search and replace type macros
so there's step one or step two so
hopefully the the forward slashes and
the backslashes are quite not quite so
scary after all this
now let's look at the uh the the tool
that we can run this piece of code or
this model so there's something there's
lots of different tools the one I'm
going to use is called the TLA plus
toolbox which is kind of an IDE and this
is what it looks like it's actually
written in Java and it's about it's over
10 years old
so it looks kind of ancient it looks
very unmodern however it does work
and it works fine so I recommend you use
this if you're doing it so here we have
my screen and I basically paste my code
in there I'll type my code in there and
the first thing you do is just make sure
there's no syntax errors
and then what you do is you create a
model
for this piece of code
and in the model you say what is the
initial State and what are the various
transitions you can do and that's what
I've done here you can just like tell
the tell the the model what those things
are and then what you do is you run the
model checker
so let me actually run the model checker
here we go here is my my code here
and here is my model
and I'm going to go run
and here it is running run run run
and it looks like I've got some sort of
error
it actually says
deadlock reached and if you look down
here it says it starts off at one and it
goes to two and it goes to three and
then it had some sort of error
all right
so what's what's going on here right
um there are three states which is one
two three but we get this deadlock so
deadlock sounds bad what does deadlock
mean
um what deadlock means is that and by
the way these traces are really useful
and we'll we'll see these later on it
basically tells you what it's trying to
do and so you can actually figure out
this is the way you kind of debug this
thing you can look at the states and see
where they are
so what happened is it got to three
and then there was nothing it could do
after three
now remember I said these things are
supposed to be kind of an infinite
series of trans transitions
so it hit three and there was nothing it
could do and it's that's what a deadlock
is a deadlock is when you cannot make
any forward progress like two two people
are trying to write to this file neither
can write to the file neither of them do
anything that's a deadlock right so
deadlock just means nobody can do
anything
and this state you in this case you hit
three and then there's nothing you can
do so that's the deadlock
so uh
this this little model Deadlocks when it
hits three that's no good so how can how
can we fix it right we're going to have
to always think of these things as
infinite series well the answer is we
just transition to three every single
time when we hit three the valid
transition is transitioning to three
again and then transitioning to three
again and then transition to three again
right so at that point we can now have
an infinite series of these threes
and these are all valid transitions so
if we add these as transitions it can
make forward progress right it hasn't
it's not changing the state very much
but it is at least you know moving
forward along the the series of
transitions so we're going to add that
to the model
so basically we're literally adding a
Becky little loop on that when when it
hits three you can just keep looping
around and hitting three over and over
again
and there's a keyword in TLA saying
unchanged
so this last one I've added a new one
called done right
and the done step is when X is before X
is three and afterwards X is unchanged
right so it's basically X is still three
so when we add this to our model and we
run the model it works really well
okay so we won this we don't get any
more Deadlocks which is very good so TLA
is happy
okay now let's move on to the next thing
which is
doing nothing is actually always an
option when you're modeling a state
machine
because let's say that I'm ticking every
second I go you know I go from one to
two and then I go from two to three and
I'm just ticking along now let's say
that I'm at one and then a millisecond
later I go to I stay on one I transition
to one
okay and then the clock ticks I go to
two and then a millisecond later I go to
two
and then clock ticks I go three in the
millisecond line I go this is exactly
the same system the fact that it didn't
do anything you know for a millisecond
this you know for a logical point of
view it's exactly the same system you
can't tell them apart right so being
able to do nothing
is always almost always about adoption
right so here I'm just transitioning
back to the same number again
so staying in the same in the same state
there's almost always about sometimes
it's not sometimes you don't want to do
that but in a lot of cases it's really
common that you want to do that because
you know things might just not you know
they can just do nothing for a while
it's not a problem so the word for that
the jargon word for that is stuttering I
mean it just kind of stays around just
goes around a little Loop so if you were
stuttering that's what they're talking
about nothing nothing's changing
so now let's add stuttering
to our little model here
so instead of being able to transition
to two we'll say well it can stay at one
that's all right and then instead of
transition to three you can stay at two
for a little bit that's right that
didn't do any harm right so we've added
a new uh thing to our model saying it
can either do step one or it can do step
two or it can be in the done state or
nothing happens
when that's all good
so that's our model updated with
stuttering which like I say most models
should have stuttering because that's
the real world
all right now let's do some properties
so this is where we are not no longer
you think that's a lot of work to
counter three I could do it in frogging
language in three lines of code but what
you can't do is the kinds of things that
TLA can do which is temporal properties
so let's look at these so a property is
something that applies to the entire
system over time not just to like
individual states with entire system
because we're going to make assumptions
or predicates about the entire system
and these properties again like does it
deadlock does it ever get to the end we
are really bad at doing this kind of
thing and programming languages don't do
this either and that's why you need
something like TLA TLA is excellent at
doing this kind of thing so let's look
at some properties we can check in our
system a nice property is something is
something always true right is the queue
always within bounds
um
you know is the is the file system
always active is the server's always
online in this model we could say is it
always true that X is greater than zero
it's really simple okay
so hopefully it's true
now eventually true is a nice one
that means it's not true right now but
hopefully at some point we'd expect it
become true hopefully if we got a bunch
of servers and we would hope that at
least one of them would serve a file at
some point
eventually always means that it gets
eventually something happens and when it
gets to that thing it's done and it
stays there forever
right so if you're doing like if you're
doing a server upgrade you eventually
get to the upgrade thing and at some
point the upgrade's done and it's and
it's done right or in this stream press
we count to three when we reach three
we're done we're not that's you know So
eventually always it should be three and
then the last one is you know the
implication if you hit two does that
imply there's going to become three at
some point later so all of these things
look like they should be true for our
system right
so how do we how do we do this in TLA
so again in English I'd say x is always
greater than two oh sorry as a bug you
should be always greater than zero there
so in mathematical terms we have to turn
it into predicate we have to say it's
always true
that this this predicate this predicate
is always true and the predicate here is
X is greater than zero
and they always operate in TLA plus is
this
square brackets
uh the eventually so instead of saying
at some point x is two we see it's
eventually this predicate eventually
becomes true So eventually the predicate
x equals two is true and in TLA plus we
use angle brackets for that
X eventually becomes three and then
stays there so mathematically would say
it's eventually true that it's always
true that x equals three
right and we use angle brackets for the
base square brackets
and then if x ever does become two then
it should become three and so we say if
the predicate x equals two is true that
implies that at some point the predicate
x equals three is true and so we have
the kind of curly wavy Arrow okay so
let's write this as code
so actually I'm rather than saying
greater than so I'm going to say it's
always within bounds so always within
bounds means it's always greater than
equal to one and less than equal to
three right
so you can see I've got the the greater
than one I've got the uh the and sorry
the or the upside down a so it's either
great or equal one actually no so it's
and so it's not it's great equal to one
and it's less than equal to three and
the whole thing is with the square
bracket so it's always true
eventually eventually two is that x
equals 2 eventually that's going to
happen so this little angle brackets
there
eventually always x equals three so when
it does hit three it's always going to
be three after that
and then again if x equals two then it
implies that x equals three later on so
here's our three and we just like write
this in the code we just add this to our
file and this is something you can't do
in a program language right we're added
to file and then what we do is we tell
the model Checker check these properties
are these properties always true
and let's run the model Checker
um well let's see what do you think
what's going to happen if we want the
model checker
let's go let me just go over here and uh
go to the next poll here
if I win the model Checker how many
properties will be true all of them
three of them two of them or just one of
them okay
there are there are properties there
see what people think
most people think that all of them will
be true it looks like okay okay yes some
of them three of them two of them
it looks like most people think all of
them are going to be true
right if we actually run the model
Checker what does it say it actually
gives an error so it's not true
turns out that only one of them are true
okay because if you look at the the
trace it says it goes to one
and then does stuttering which means it
stays on one
right so people forgot about stuttering
I told you all about it and then you
forgot about it so what it means it
starts at one and then it just Loops
back to One Forever
so that's never going to get to two and
it's never going to get to three
and even if it did get two it gets they
could just loop around on two forever
it's never going to get to three
so both of these things these states you
can just go around forever and never go
anywhere so we've just ruined our model
yes
is
true in almost narrative yes yeah
yeah and it's just going to go around
one and you know it's just going to
start at one and just stay on one
forever so by adding stuttering we've
actually ruined our model we had a nice
model at work and now we've broken it
okay now and I said but we should we
should have stuttering so we've got a
kind of conflict we should have
stuttering but on the hand as soon as we
add stuttering it breaks everything
so in this case the the only one that is
always true is the always within band so
even though it stays on white it's
always true that it's between one and
three
even though we've broken the rest of it
so let's fix that
what we really want to do is say
okay you can go around a few times but
you should try some of the other ones
sometimes right don't just stay in an
infinite Loop like if you can go some
other place if you can transition to two
you know every so often give it a go
don't always always do the same thing go
in a stain for Loop
right so don't stay in envelope try
different things that's called fairness
right be fair like give each of the Tran
possible if you've got two transitions
you can choose from
use both of them every so often I don't
always pick one and never use the other
one that's not fair right use both of
them so that's called fairness
right and then of course TLA recognizes
this is a really important thing and it
has a concept where you can model this
in TLA Plus
so how do we model it in tlf first of
all I'm going to have to refactor the
code a little bit and the syntax
unfortunately is a little bit ugly now
we're getting into this all the ugly
syntax so first of all I'm going to take
the spec that we had and we're going to
merge the initial State and the next
thing into one single
uh thing which I'm calling spec
so this this is the specification for
the entire systems it starts off as the
initial and
then the next one is just always
um the next thing or unchanged
all right so it's always either to
always do with the next step or leave it
X on change so that's our refactoring
now it turns out there's a nice bit of
syntax sugar for this so instead of
saying next
or unchanged there's actually a little
bit of syntax you could say with square
brackets around underscore X now it
looks really ugly
um that's because it's not been
formatted by latex yet once it has been
formatted you have a nice little
subscript X would be a little subscript
but this kind of looks ugly because this
is designed to be
you know this is designed to be
formatted code it's not it's time to be
like programming language
so that's the Syntax for try to do next
or
don't do anything
now now that we've got this syntax we
can actually add another piece which is
this fairness
WF underscore X next and what that means
is you can stutter a few times but make
sure you try doing the next you know
don't don't always pick the same thing
try both of them okay and that's called
weak fairness there's another one called
strong fairness which I'm not going to
talk about but weak fairness just means
try things when you when you come to a
branch in the road try both of them
don't always pick the same one
okay so that's what that means now if
you add that
so and we here we add our weak fairness
to our design and we have our bound our
properties like we had before with the
weak fairness if we run it it does work
so we can we can have the stuttering and
still
prove that the various properties happen
if we have weak fairness
so that's good so I was obviously
thinking it's going to ruin everything
but no it doesn't actually ruin
everything weak fairness you need to use
this quite a lot sometimes okay and this
these four properties this is where TLA
plus is not a programming language you
could not do this in python or
JavaScript
you couldn't say are you sure that it
will eventually become free are you sure
that it will never go out of bounds
parking languages can't do that but TLA
plus can
right now let's move the next one Let's
uh go back and model those producer
consumer ones okay and let's see if we
can get some more confidence in that
code
so here here again we have our producer
and it's again it's checking whether
it's writable and if so it can write and
the consumer checks whether it's
readable and if so it reads okay so each
one has two steps so how do we model
this as a state machine
well there's two steps this there's two
states and two transitions so the first
state is it's ready to start the whole
process it's idle as it were the first
thing it does is check is the queue
writable is the queue not full
and if it is ready then I kind of
transition into a state where okay I'm
just about to write I'm ready to write
my thing and we're not doing this like I
said we're not doing this as an atomic
operation
because that would be too easy right in
the real and in the real world you can't
always do it as an atomic operation so
am I the first thing is am I ready to
write and then if I am in that ready to
write State then I can actually write
something to queue and then I go back to
being idle okay
so two State Transitions and two
transitions so in a programming language
I would write the code like this you
know if the producer state is in the
ready
and the queue is ready you know is less
than the maximum then I can assign the
producer state to the next state
and then the second transition I would
say well if the producer is in the ready
to write state
then change it back to the ready State
and then also increment the queue size
now I actually don't care about the
queue I don't care what the contents of
the queue are I don't care about how the
queue is implemented all I care about is
is the is the queue going to get too
full is it going to overflow or
underflow that's all I care about so I'm
just going to model the queue is this a
model it's not the real code right so
I'm just going to model the queue as an
integer and every time I write to the
queue I'm just going to increment the
integer every time I read from the queue
I'm just going to decrement the integer
that's all I need to do so that's that's
the modeling I'm doing into this queue I
don't really care how the queue actually
works foreign
so that's the programming version let's
look at the TLA plus version so again
before the transition
the producer state is ready and the
queue size is less than the max
afterwards now just produce a state with
a little tick next to it afterwards the
producer state is now in the can weight
and the queue size is unchanged you have
to say for every single thing you have
to say what happens to it and in this
case for this one nothing happens to the
queue size
that's very important
now what about the what the right
transition so the right transition is
assuming that before the producer state
is ready to write
and afterwards the producer State goes
back to being kind of idle and now
afterwards the cue size is queue size
plus one so I just think of it so this
is how you would write this stuff in TLA
so it's not quite the same as the
programming thing it's all notice this
is a giant predicate everything is an
and an or
right I'm not really doing any kind of
calculations so this these transitions
are only available so for example if the
queue is
full and a producer is in the ready
State the first transition is not
available so the model Checker can't
choose that transition because it's not
available to choose because it doesn't
meet the requirements right so these are
think of these things as predicates
right they always return true or false
it's not assignments
it's if if if the if the preconditions
are true then it can use this transition
if the preconditions aren't true it
can't use the transition so if there was
if you know if the queue
Max Q size was Zero
that would be a deadlock right the the
the
producer could never transition between
states and the consumer could never
transition between states and the whole
thing would just be a massive deadlock
so you know if you have an empty if you
have a zero length queue then you've got
a deadlock so
now the producer action overall is a
choice between trying to do the first
thing try to do the second thing so
that's we've modeled the producer action
as a choice something or something again
it's the upside down
uh triangle
now we do exactly the same thing in the
consumer
this time it's reading from the queue
there's two different states there's two
different transitions so we check the
first thing we do is check whether it's
readable or not
and the other transition is we can check
we try to write sorry try to read and
when we read we're just decrementing
that you can see queue size
cue size equals is minus one so we're
just popping from the keyword
and again the all the possible consumer
actions is we either do the first
transition or we try and do the second
transition
right so that's the consumer side done
now let's put it together into an entire
system let's actually I'm just going to
put the entire piece of code on the
screen here
so that's the this now is all the
producer side of things here
um this is all the consumer side of
things here
and finally the overall all the possible
transitions we can do
is either we can try doing a position
thing or we can try doing a consumer
thing
that is everything we can do right
so what's nice is we get non-determinism
for free like if I was trying to model
it in code I'd have to have threads or
I'd have to have actors or something
right it'd be kind of tricky to model
this
but in TLA plus it's just a choice it's
like in when your model sometimes do the
producer thing if you can sometimes do a
consumer thing if you can and you can
alternate between them you know the
model Checker will try all the possible
combinations of doing these things so
it's just do one or the other and now
we've got non-determinism because it
will automatically every time you have a
choice it will try them both you know
now do we add stuttering right should we
add some stuttering where nothing
happens
um maybe it may be not in this case
maybe this is a case where you don't
want to have it but if you did have it
you could that would be an example where
the consumer just stops working so if
the consumer stops working it doesn't do
anything does the producer keep adding
things to the queue and overflowing the
queue does your code check for that you
know
so maybe the producers just the consumer
is just not working just taking time off
a couple of minutes and having a coffee
break you know
right now what are the the temporal
properties so the first the most
important one the most important one is
is it always within bounce right so is
the queue size
um non-empty well sorry greater than or
equal zero and is the queue size less
than the max
all right so it's either that one or
so it ends you see at the end and all
stuff it's either it must be greater
than equal to zero and it must be less
than equal to the Max and then we have
the the angle brackets I'm sorry the
square bracket which means it's always
true so this predicate with both of
these things are always true
now if we won this script we don't get
any errors
so that means with one producer and one
consumer this design works all right we
have confidence in this design
now I think that when I did this the
first poll
it was 50 50. some people thought it
wouldn't work some people thought it
would work
um
so with a single producer and a single
consumer yes this actually does design
does work we don't need to guess we're
actually doing the model checking so if
I revisit this screen that I had before
and I go to the next poll
um there we go so now how many people
are confident
that the single producer single consumer
one uh oh everyone's confident okay very
good
yeah so it was 50 50 before
and I think the confidence level is much
higher because I've run this little tool
and it's checked everything and I'm
pretty sure that it's not it's not
broken
some people are still not confident
that's correct
so I don't know how would I persuade you
I would just take you through this in
more detail and and go through the model
checking in more detail
but the answer is this actually is
correct
so
right let's keep going
um now now let's do the multiversion one
with two consumers and two producers or
more than one and this is where we need
the Plus in TLA Plus
so the plus is mostly set theory and um
again TLA plus uses a mathematical type
of set theory so for example in
programming if I were to say given a set
find all the elements that have this
certain property we would say something
like set.filter right something like
that in mathematical terms we'd say the
elements in the set such that this
predicate is true
so we'd write it in a mathematical way
and in TLA plus we write it that way we
say curly braces e slash in so just
again latex is going to format that as a
little um
uh you know Greek e
such that there's predicate is true so
it basically TLA turns this into like
nice mathematical notation
and again if I'm saying is there any
element in the set which has this
property in programming we would say
something like set.ne probably you know
I don't know but in TLA plus we'd say
does there exist an element in the set
such that the predicate is true
so that's how you'd write it in TLA plus
and it gets converted into the
mathematical
formatting like when you run it through
latex it formats it the other way
so there you go okay so when you see
that stuff that's what's going all these
slashes
that's the latex formatting okay so we
need since we're doing two producers two
consumers we have a set no one no longer
just one no longer
um just one consumer so now we're going
to need the set part of TLA plus so
here's a set of producers we have two
probably good enough P1 and P2 and we
have two consumers C1 C2
right now how do we we need to change
our spec to work with multiple producers
so um first of all we need to initialize
everything so we're going to initialize
the producer States
to be every single producer is in the
first state in the ready state
now you can think of these this set is
actually like a dictionary in python or
something it's a map especially a bunch
of key value pairs so in Python I could
have written P1 colon ready P2 column
ready it means they're both ready in um
TLA plus you don't use that syntax you
say for the set in all every p in the
set producers you assign it to ready
okay and same thing with consumers so
these states are like I say think of
them as dictionaries or or
Maps they are not just the sets of key
value pairs
now let's do the writable side now this
time we're parameterizing by a
particular producer
so this particular producer for this
transition to happen this particular
producer has to be in the ready State
and the queue has to be less than the
right size
and now afterwards we're updating the
state now this dictionary
every single thing is the same except
for this particular producer is now
changed so the syntax is kind of weird
you say the the producer state is
exactly the same except that this
particular producer is now in the next
state
but all the other ones are unchanged
so that's why you see this kind of
accept syntax
um and let's look at the again I'm
parameterized by producer we check the
state for this particular so this is a
Dictionary lookup for this particular
producer and this is like updating the
dictionary this is the TLA way of
updating a dictionary rather than just
assigning to the key
and now we're going to do the right in
the same way again it's the it's got
this thing where you update the
dictionary for this producer now we've
got a whole bunch of producers we can't
just say do one or the other what we're
going to say is
find any producer where we can do either
of these actions like some producers
might be in the middle of reading some
writing somebody some of them might be
idle we're just going to pick one at
random try and find one that we can do a
transition on and again we'll we'll take
turns because it's fair we'll try each
of them right
so that's how we do that same thing with
the consumers exactly the same kind of
thing I'm going to start whizzing
through this light and say don't worry
too much about understanding every
single line of code I'm just trying to
show you the overall concepts of how TLA
plus would model this kind of thing but
again we have a kind of a dictionary for
the consumers and if this particular
consumer is ready we update the
dictionary and assign this particular
Sumer to ready to read
and the second transition is the same
way and then the consumer action in
general is
does there exist a consumer that we can
either read or you know or or or check
the readability for
so try and find a consumer that has a
valid action that we can do
now if we run the script with two
producers and two consumers and that
same always and Bounds property what do
you think happens
first of all
the possibilities of one is reading and
the other one's writing and this one
then a two reading at the same time and
there's one all those possibilities the
38 combinations just with two producers
and two consumers
way way too much there's no way we can
do a code inspection for that
now of course this does not work okay
this we are very confident that this
design does not work
so when I've told you before I think
some people thought it might work it's
like no this is this does not work
definitely doesn't and some people
weren't confident like I am 100
confident it does not work
so we're not guessing so how do we fix
the error well TLA plus does not tell
you how to fix it right you have to
think
you have to find out what is the right
way to model a producer consumer
however what it is good is testing the
fix
so let's say I'm going to use a
semaphore or I'm going to use a mutex
I'm going to use whatever it is that I
think would fix this problem I'm going
to add the semaphore logic into my model
I'm going to rerun the model and see if
it works right so if the model if I
rewind the model with semaphores and it
works
I'm pretty confident that I could then
go and code this with semaphores and
I've got my semaphore logic right which
is always kind of tricky too so you've
got a lot more confidence that the fix
will work or not maybe maybe I got my
semaphore logic wrong and it doesn't
work so either way I've got some
confidence there so this is 50 lines of
code
and we have a lot of confidence either
way on the on the design so it's
definitely worth doing I think
now okay last bit which is TLA modeling
um uh how are we doing a Time
using TLA plus the model zero downtime
deployment so this is a real world
example of if you're doing devops and
you need to you know do a zero downtime
deployment
so I'm going to go even faster here so
again don't worry too much about the
details
but I just want to kind of show you that
TLA plus is a great tool to improve your
design because what we're going to do is
sketch the design I want to like let's
think let's try it this way we're going
to check it with the model Checker and
the model Checker is probably going to
say no you got it wrong we're going to
fix it I'm going to try again and the
model check will say no you still got it
wrong fix it try again and when the
model Checker says I got it right then
it's like yeah and now I'm pretty
confident that my code is good okay
so I'm going to steal this from Hillel
Wayne who is a TLA expert and I'm going
to talk about him later on at the end of
The Talk
so how are we going to let's come up
with our model okay we have a bunch of
servers
and each server is going to be upgraded
from version one to version two
but here's the problem each server goes
offline during the upgrade
right and we really want to make sure
that there's always a server that's
online
right that's really critical
and here's another thing all the servers
must be upgraded because a really easy
way to implement this is never upgrade a
server then they're always online so we
have to have two conditions I mean you
have to be very careful having them
always be online is easy if they if
you've never actually bother to upgrade
them so you want to make sure that at
the end of this process every single
server is at version two
right so that's the estragal uh kicker
there so how do we model this as a
series of State transitions well we're
going to have three states and two
transitions right it starts off it's
online and it's in version one and then
we start the upgrade and it goes offline
then we finish the upgrade and it goes
back online and it's now at version two
okay that's our entire model
and then went to version two it can keep
looping forever right we've got that
little thing where it's done and we can
just keep going so we have to add that
to stop it having a deadlock right
so again we're going to have a
dictionary of key value Pairs and the
server state in this case the server
state for each server is going to be one
of these three things online V1 offline
or online V2 so initially every single
server is version one that's the initial
State now the start transition is we
pick a server which is in V1
and then we upgrade to be offline that
particular one
and then to finish the upgrade we pick a
server that's offline
and we update it to be online with
version two so that's our start
transition and that's our finished
transition
all right and then the doing any
upgraders we try and find does there
exist a server that we can upgrade
so we try and upgrade a server which
means um trying to do either the start
transition or the finished transition
and there's also another one which is
done right all the servers are in
version two
so slash a means for all servers instead
of servers the server State is online
and at that point we can leave the
server State unchanged that's that
little backwards Loop so we have an
upgrade step and we have the done step
so the overall
thing is either try doing an upgrade and
if we can't do an upgrade try doing the
done
now so let's run our script
there are three states now with one
server there's three possible States
with two servers there's nine possible
states with three servers there's 27
possible States so for example I could
upgrade number one and upgrade number
two and start number three or I could do
number one and go through all things and
then leave these alone or I could do
this two steps forward and this one one
step forward and leave this you know
this is complicated there's all sorts of
things all sorts of combinations of
things that you could do and you you
wouldn't really be some weird
combination might happen that you didn't
think about so it's again it's too hard
to eyeball
so now what the temporal properties so
first of all zero down time so what does
that mean not all servers should be
offline at once okay and then the
upgrade should complete that means that
at some point it eventually always
all the servers should be version two
okay so let's write that as a TLA code
here so zero downtime means it's always
true
that there is a server which is not
offline
right it's always true that there exists
a server such that the server state is
not Offline that slash equals is not
equal it's instead of using bang you
call it uses slash equal okay so it's
always true there's a server which isn't
offline okay it's ever done time
now this eventually upgraded okay so
it's eventually
all the servers in the set of servers
will have a server state which is
version two
right so we've modeled that in TLA Plus
now if we run this script with two
servers we get this invariant zero
downtime is VAR and it's violated right
I thought I thought we had a perfect
algorithm here
so we look at the trace for the model
Checker and it says at the beginning S1
and S2 are both online at V1 we take S1
offline and then we take S2 offline
well boom now we're both offline we've
looked we've broken our constraint
well that was stupid so how can we fix
that how can we fix that well we'll add
another step
okay we're going to add a fix but are we
confident that our fix will work
let's see
so what I'm going to do is add another
con a trend uh for the start upgrade I'm
going to say you can only start
upgrading if nobody else is offline okay
so there's my start Trend my start
upgrade I'm going to add a new step
is does there exist another server where
the other server state is offline and if
that's true
don't don't start an upgrade okay so if
somebody else is offline you're not
allowed to upgrade
so that's my fix for this problem and
now if I run the script this time with
two servers zero downtime actually works
we guarantee there's no downtime because
there's you know if you can't start an
upgrade if someone else is offline so
you can never have two people offline at
the same time that's great
rather eventually upgrade fails
why does it fail
because of the stuttering
we haven't said we can just say stay in
version one forever
don't do it don't do the upgrade how can
we force the upgrade to happen we need
to add this fairness thing like if you
can upgrade at some point you must
upgrade you at least try upgrading don't
just stay in an info Loop and never
upgrade like if you can't if there's at
some point in the system where you know
everywhere else is upgraded and you're
the last one you at least have to try it
okay so adding fairness then makes it
all work so that's good
now let's add another condition so you
know this is good we're sketching our
model we're playing around we're getting
confidence now let's add a more strict
condition which is that all the online
servers have to be running the same
version they all have to be running V1
or V2 but you can't have a mix because
if we have a mix of V1 and V2 it's going
to mess up our clients
so how do we model that well first of
all we Define a set of servers which are
online so we say online servers are the
set of servers where they are not
offline
okay that's easy enough and now we want
something which is always true it's
always true
that for the set of servers which are
online
if you pick any two of them they will
have the same server state they're both
bv1 or both vv2
but they will not they won't be
different so that is our same version
requirement that's our constraint for
same version
so he run the script with a new property
boom we get an error
and then if we look at this trace of
what's happening it says well first of
all they were both V1
and then S1 went offline and S2 is still
V1 and then S2 S1 got upgraded to V2 and
S2 hasn't even started upgrade
so now they're both the different
versions the first one is V2 and second
three one and we we meet our requirement
so we have confidence that that fix did
not actually work okay now how can we
fix this I'm going to suggest we use a
load balancer
so the load balancer is going to only
point to V1 servers or only point to V2
servers and you're not going to mix them
in so from a client's point of view I'm
only going to see the same version
so let's how do we Implement a load
balancer to see so the initial of state
is now we're going to have a new thing
called a load balancer and again from
the model point of view I don't actually
need to implement a load band so all I
need to do is say is it version one or
version two
so it's just going to say am I pointing
to version One servers or version two
servers how's it actually happens in the
real thing I don't care because this is
a model I'm just doing the very Basics
right
so the online servers are now slightly
different if the load balance is V1
the online servers are all the ones
which are V1 and if the load balancer is
a V2 the online servers are all the ones
which are V2
so that's our that's how we would model
our load balancer now obviously the real
thing is a lot more complicated but from
a model this is you know this we're
trying to keep it simple here
now when can the load balancer switch
from pointer to V1 service to poignant
to V2 servers well it can switch when
one server has been successfully
upgraded or you've you know you could
see maybe two servers but you know for
this case any if any server upgrades to
V2 I can switch the load balancer to
point to it okay
so we now have a new step in our in our
finishing upgrade which is if if an
upgrade is essentially finished the load
balancer can now be version two
so now if we run the script with the
load balancer the zero downtime works
you never have any downtime everything
is eventually upgraded and
the same version works
so if I just run the code I'd prove it
to you go back here
zero down time
open up the model
and you can see here is The Code by the
way
so you know it's like 50 lines of code
it's not that much here are all our
properties zero downtime eventually
upgraded same version right
right we take this model we run it
and it runs it and it's checking all the
possible States
and uh no errors
now if you said I want the load balance
to always have at least two servers
um you know which you might want to do
then you'd have to have I've only got
two servers in here so it's never going
to work but if you had like model it
with five servers and you could say at
least two have to be up at all times or
something you can just you can see you
could extend the model to do that kind
of thing really easily
yay
so who thinks this algorithm is now
right
I just ran the model Checker and it
didn't give me any errors
do you think this algorithm is right the
algorithm I just showed you
what is your confidence in the design of
this zero downtime deployment process
like the first one didn't work
and then I added various fixes and I've
run it through the model checker
and this is good so it looks like people
now there's a few people who are not 100
confident
um yeah some people are not confident
either way but it's a lot more than it
was at the beginning when people were
100 people are not common at all
so the people who are not confident
either way or the people who don't think
it's correct
um you know
obviously we have to go into more detail
this but I think I could prove I think I
could if I spent a couple hours with you
I think I could convince you that this
actually was a correct algorithm Maybe
not maybe I'm wrong maybe I missed
something
okay so that's our sketch complete and
again we just only spent 10 minutes on
it so you can actually think of it as
sort of agile modeling
right for concurrent systems so we're
doing some sketch we're playing with
some things we're finding out certain
things don't work certain things do work
it's all about getting confidence
so the most common question and I'm just
I'm sorry a bit of a few minutes over
I'm just finishing up now the most
common question people say how do you
convert this to code right the answer is
it doesn't convert to code it's not a
code generator it's a model just like if
I have a wooden model of a building it
doesn't magically Sprout and turn into a
giant skyscraper right it's a model it's
a way for thinking about the building
but it's not the actual construction
process
so it's again it's all about having
confidence in the design before you
start writing code
so that's model checking for you okay so
hopefully you can see that TLA plus it's
not actually that scary the syntax looks
a bit weird but the whole thing of model
checking is it's just a nice thing to
have it's not that scary
um it's really nice for sketching things
in a few hours you can actually play
with it and get some confidence in your
design I would say if you're doing
anything with concurrency it's really
really important I actually would say
it's essential and it's just another
tool in your toolbox you know you know
how to do unit tests you know how to do
um
type driven design or whatever tdd or
whatever it's like you know these are
just tools you have it's another tool in
your toolbox that I think is a
professional developer you should at
least have some knowledge about
now TLA plus is really big system it can
do way more than I just showed you I'm
just doing a tiny tiny piece of what it
can do
but you're not even going to get into
that so if you want more information on
TLA plus there's a pay as a home page
there's a videos there's books there's
papers there's a long book by Leslie
Lampert
um it's a bit mathematical but it's not
actually that hard but if you want a
more programmer friendly thing check out
stuff by Hillel Wayne he has a book
called learn TLA he has a website called
learn to lay and he does trainings for
pro programmer-centric trainings so if
you are involved in concurrency and you
want to learn more you know obviously a
more deep in-depth thing check him out
and and he'll do a training for your
team
so I'm going to put the slides and video
up here on my website the F sharp final
profit TLA plus
um if you want more about property-based
testing I also have stuff about that I
have my book which people seem to like
and you can contact me on Twitter and
thank you very much I'll be here I don't
have time for questions but I will I'll
stick around here if you've got
questions for me so thank you very much
for coming
[Applause]